Recall that by default, the browser assumes that
css is blocking, hence the first link tag will
block rendering. The screen query will evaluate the true,
since we are rendering the content on the screen
and hence it will also block rendering. The
third declaration depends on the orientation of the device.
In this particular case because the handset is in
portrait orientation. It won't be a render blocking resource.
Finally, the last declaration is only applied
when the page is being printed. Hence,
it is not render blocking when the page is first being loaded in the browser.
>> Nice. So, only two of the four are
render blocking. I can feel the pages getting faster already.